How is Marvel’s “Black Panther” franchise
going to continue without Chadwick Boseman?
And what’s with that strange ceremony with
everyone wearing white?
Keep watching to find out more small details
you may have missed in the “Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever” trailer.
“Wakanda Forever!”
It's a remarkable achievement that "Black
Panther: Wakanda Forever" even made it to
the finish line.
Chadwick Boseman, who plays T'Challa, aka
Black Panther, in the first film, passed away
at the age of 43 in 2020, leaving behind shoes
that were impossible to fill.
"There aren't words to express what an amazing
human being Chadwick Boseman was"
Marvel fans everywhere were captivated by
his performance in "Black Panther," and it's
one of the many factors that led to the film
being nominated for several Academy Awards in 2019.
Fortunately, Marvel opted not to try and recast
another actor as T'Challa.
Instead, it appears the studio will center
the sequel story around T'Challa's younger
sister, Shuri, his mother, Queen Ramonda,
Nakia, Okoye, and other characters from the
2018 movie, all the while finding a way to
honor the legacies of Boseman and his character.
At least, that's what it looks like based
on the first trailer for "Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever" that debuted on Saturday evening
at San Diego Comic-Con 2022.
The teaser trailer for the second "Black Panther"
feature indicates there is still plenty of
life left in this beloved franchise.
In addition to boasting plenty of important
characters from the previous movie, the teaser
introduces the audience to some new players
and hints at other mystical worlds away from Wakanda.
There's plenty to unpack, so let's take a
look at some of the smaller details you may
have missed.
The first third of the "Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever" trailer shows Wakanda in a state
of mourning for their late king — and most
recent Black Panther — T'Challa.
In the wake of Boseman's death, Ryan Coogler,
director of both "Black Panther" installments,
addressed the packed SDCC 2022 convention
hall and told fans that Boseman's legacy will
last far beyond the tragic early end of his
life.
He said, "I promise you, I feel his hand on
me right now, Chad's passion and the genius
and his culture and the impact he made on
this industry will be felt forever."
T'Challa's absence hangs heavy over the beginning
of the trailer.
We get brief glimpses of Shuri, Nakia, Okoye,
and his mother, Queen Ramonda in various displays
of sadness or stoicism while soul sensation
Tems delivers a mournful cover of Bob Marley's
"No Woman, No Cry".
It is very clear that T'Challa's absence cuts
deep in the lives of everyone who knew him,
loved him, and fought beside him, leaving
them all to shed a tear privately or come
together as one.
“And my entire family is gone!”
We also see a large ceremony featuring a cadre
of dancers and a ceremonial procession, but
everyone wears white.
As such, it's unclear if this is a funeral
procession for T'Challa, a wedding (for Shuri,
perhaps?), or something else entirely.
As you would expect from the most senior surviving
member of the Wakandan royal family, Ramonda
is leading by example as the stone-cold and
determined figurehead of the nation.
After being separated from both her children
during The Blip in "Avengers: Infinity War,"
and then happily reunited with them at the
end of "Avengers: Endgame," the stress has
clearly taken a toll on her based on the wisps
of white hair poking out from under her headdress
as she gazes across the beach.
Ramonda appears to be navigating the very
public, very exacting duty of leading a nation
while struggling with the death of her son.
It's a tough road ahead for the queen, but
she has the support she needs to get her through.
This includes her daughter Shuri, who is by
her side and ready to put on a strong front.
But it doesn't seem like the Wakandan princess
will focus much on her brilliant engineering
skills — or, at least, they’ll take a
backseat to more important matters.
At one point in the "Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever" teaser trailer, we see her participating
in the royal duties, including taking part
in what appears to be a funeral procession
(unless it's something more celebratory?)
and recruiting help from Riri Williams.
Yes, that's right — fans will meet Ironheart
before she takes the spotlight in her upcoming
solo Disney+ series of the same name.
Of all the exciting details that the new teaser
for "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever" offers,
seeing Namor and the rest of the Atlanteans
for the first time will probably make Marvel
fans jump right out of their seats.
Not even one minute into the trailer, fans
can see what appears to be an Atlantean couple
giving birth to a new child — which could
possibly be a young Namor.
In a haunting shot just past the one-minute
mark, it appears that Atlanteans and what
might be a young Namor are watching a building
burn.
It then immediately transitions to him walking
out of the water as an adult, appearing far
more stately and adorned with additional Atlantean
regalia.
We also get plenty of shots of the Atlantean
community.
The trailer isn't shy with its breathtaking
shots of the underwater way of life the citizens
of Atlantis live.
Scenes of a crew of Atlanteans riding a humpback
whale and a squad of Atlantean fighters facing
off against an unseen foe on dry land are
sure to stick in our minds until we see this movie.
Marvel Comics' Atlanteans have been around
on Earth for some time, along with Namor,
although they technically immigrated from
the planet Vodan long ago.
Namor is the son of a human father and an
Atlantean princess.
He is also one of the most powerful and intelligent
beings in the Marvel universe.
In fact, in Marvel Comics, Namor has been
part of the Illuminati, the group that makes
their live-action debut in "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness."
"Wanda stop, you possessed an innocent woman
but you can still do the right thing: let her go."
It will be interesting to see what we learn
of Namor and the origins of the Atlanteans
in the MCU — as they are known to make alterations
from comic’s origins sometimes.
IGN first reported in August 2021 that Riri
Williams — also known as Ironheart – would
appear in "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever,"
and the new trailer confirms it.
Played by Dominique Thorne, Riri Williams
is a relatively newer character in Marvel
comics history.
A genius, Riri is only a teenager when she
begins her studies at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology, where she creates an advanced
suit of armor in honor of her favorite hero, Iron Man.
In the "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever" trailer,
Riri is first greeted in Shuri's lab with
a hand slap from the Wakandan royal, who seems
to know her well.
Later, Queen Ramonda delivers a speech and
asks, "Have I not given everything?"
as various scenes play in the background.
One of those scenes seems to show Riri forging
her Ironheart suit of armor as a piece of
heart-shaped armor falls to the floor.
It looks like we'll not only get to meet Riri,
but we'll also get to see her in action as
the metal-clad superhero.
It's unclear how large of a role Ironheart
will play in the forthcoming "Black Panther"
sequel, but the character's future looks bright
in the MCU.
Aside from the riveting performance by Chadwick
Boseman in the titular role, one of the biggest
standouts in "Black Panther" was his nemesis,
Killmonger.
Micheal B. Jordan's take on the villain brought
a solid performance of a grounded and somewhat
relatable opposition to T'Challa's claim to
the throne.
The fact that one could watch "Black Panther"
and not wholly disagree with his perspective
made Killmonger one of the best villains in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
While fans on Reddit have wondered if they
would see Jordan return as T'Challa's villainous
cousin, his death at the end of the 2018 hit
pic made it unlikely.
The trailer, however, gives us a sneak peek
at the new Black Panther suit at the end.
Opening its claws on a beach and preparing
for battle, it is almost impossible not to
notice the signature gold details.
Those elements are not on the suit worn by
T'Challa.
Instead, they adorn the suit worn by Killmonger
in the cousins' climactic "Black Panther" face-off.
His suit seems to be back, but is Killmonger
returning as well?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.